pouvait imaginer qu'en un an à peine le
monde déjà bouleversé par une crise
économique sans précédent allait à ce
point changé en quelques mois
les printemps arabes ont fait lever une
immense espérance depuis trop longtemps
des peuples arabes soumis à l'oppression
ont pu relever la tête et ont réclamé le
droit d'être enfin libre avec leurs
mains nues
ils se sont opposés à la violence et à
la brutalité
à ceux qui proclamait que le monde arabo
musulman était par nature hostile à la
démocratie et aux droits de l'homme les
jeunes arabes ont apporté le plus beau
des démentis et bien mesdames et
messieurs mes chers collègues nous
n'avons pas le droit de décevoir
l'espérance des peuples arabes nous
n'avons pas le droit de briser leur rêve
car si l'espérance de ces peuples
étaient brisées cela donnerait raison
aux fanatiques qui n'ont pas renoncé à
dresser l'islam contre l'occident en
attisant partout la haine et la violence
c'est un appel à la justice qui a
ébranlé le monde et le monde ne peut pas
répondre à cet appel à la justice par la
perpétuation d'une injustice ce
miraculeux printemps des peuples arabes
nous impose une obligation morale une
obligation politique de résoudre enfin
le conflit du moyen-orient
nous ne pouvons plus attendre
la méthode utilisée jusqu'à présent je
pèse mes mots a échoué
il faut donc changer de méthode il faut
arrêter de croire qu'un seul pays
j'utilise le plus grand ou qu'un petit
groupe de pays peuvent résoudre un
problème d'une telle complexité
trop d'acteurs majeurs sont laissés de
côté pour pouvoir aboutir
je voudrais dire que personne ne peut
imaginer que le processus de paix ne
puisse se passer de l'europe que
personne ne puis imaginer que le
processus de paix puisse se passer de
tous les membres permanents du conseil
de sécurité que personne ne peut
imaginer que l'on puisse se passer des
états arabes qui ont déjà fait le choix
de la paix une approche collective est
devenu indispensable pour créer de la
confiance et apporté des garanties à
chacune des parties
alors bien sûr la paix sera fait par les
israéliens et par les palestiniens
par personne d'autre et nul ne peut
prétendre la leur imposer
mais nous devons les aider
la méthode ne fonctionne plus
reconnaissant semble
voilà un petit problème technique on
écoutait le discours de nicolas sarkozy
qui s'exprimait donc depuis l'assemblée
générale des nations unies à new york
nicolas sarkozy qui s'apprêtait à
préciser la position de la france sur la
demande de reconnaissance de l'état de
palestine une demande formulée à part
mahmoud abbas une demande rejetée il y à
quelques minutes par barack obama
nicolas sarkozy donc qui va poursuivre
son déplacement lui à new york
on est qui va poursuivre son déplacement
à new york ont fait leur ai écoutés dans
quelques instants
nicolas sarkozy qui s'exprime donc
depuis à la tribune de l'assemblée
générale l'adn des nations unies on
écoute a tout de suite c'est qu'à
l'origine chômage de 10,1 mois pour
reprendre les discussions six mois pour
se mettre d'accord sur les frontières et
sur la sécurité un an pour parvenir à un
accord définitif et la france propose
d'accueillir dès cet automne une
conférence des donateurs afin que les
palestiniens puissent parachever la
construction de leur futur état
la france veut vous dire qu'il ne faut
pas chercher d'emblée la solution
parfaite parce que de solution parfaite
il n'y en a pas choisissons la voie du
compromis qui n'est pas un renoncement
qui n'est pas un reniement
mais qui permettra d'avancer étape par
étape
voilà donc 60 ans que les palestiniens
attendent leur état est ce qu'il n'est
pas venu le moment de le redonner de
l'espérance
voilà 60 ans qu'israël souffre de ne pas
pouvoir vivre en paix voici soixante ans
que la question de la coexistence
pacifique des deux peuples palestinien
et israélien demeure lancinante
nous ne pouvons plus attendre pour
prendre le chemin de la paix mettons
nous à la place des palestiniens
n'est-il pas légitime qu'ils réclament
leur état bien sûr que si et qui ne voit
que la création d'un état palestinien
démocratique viable pacifique serait
pour israël la meilleure garantie de sa
sécurité
mettons nous à la place des israéliens
n'est-il pas légitime qu'après 60 ans de
guerre et d'attentats il demande des
garanties pour cette paix si longtemps
attendu bien sûr que si et je le dis
avec force
si quiconque à travers le monde menaçait
l'existence d'israël la france serait
immédiatement et totalement aux côtés
d'israël
les menaces à l'endroit d'un état membre
des nations unies sont inacceptables et
ne seront pas acceptés alors nous sommes
aujourd'hui devant un choix très
difficile
chacun sait bien et arrêtons avec les
hypocrisies
ou la diplomatie d'un jour chacun sait
bien qu'une reconnaissance pleine et
entière du statut d'état membre de l'onu
ne peut être obtenue dans l'immédiat la
raison première en est le manque de
confiance entre les principaux acteurs
mais disons nous la vérité qui peut
douter qu'un veto au conseil de sécurité
non je n'y aura pas un cycle de violence
au proche orient qui peut en douter
faut-il pour autant exclure une étape
intermédiaire et pourquoi ne pas
envisager pour la palestine le statut
d'état observateur aux nations unies
ce serait un pas important nous
sortirions après 60 ans de l'immobilisme
l'immobilisme qui fait le lit des
extrémistes
nous redonnerions un espoir aux
palestiniens en marquant des progrès
vers le statut final et pour marquer
leur engagement déterminé en faveur
d'une paix négociée
les dirigeants palestiniens devraient
dans le cadre de cette démarche
réaffirmer le droit à l'existence et à
la sécurité d'israël
elles devraient s'engager à ne pas
utiliser ce nouveau statut pour recourir
à des actions incompatibles avec la
poursuite des négociations
mes chers collègues nous n'avons qu'une
alternative l'immobilisme et le blocage
et une solution intermédiaire qui
permettrait de donner de l'espoir aux
palestiniens avec un statut d'état
observateur
parallèlement une même retenue devrait
être observée par israël qui devraient
s'abstenir de gestes qui préjugent du
statut final
l'objectif ultime c'est bien la
reconnaissance mutuelle de deux états
nations pour deux peuples établis sur la
base des lignes de 1967 avec des
échanges de territoires agréés et
équivalents mais que cette assemblée
générale j'en ai le pouvoir décide
d'avancer décide de sortir du piège
mortel de la paralysie décide de
renvoyer les rendez vous manqués et les
relances sans lendemain
changeons de méthode changement d'état
d'esprit que chacun s'efforce de
comprendre les raisons de l'autre les
souffrances de l'autre les angoisses de
l'autre que chacun ouvre les yeux et
soit prêt à faire des concessions et en
terminant je veux le dire avec une
profonde et sincère amitié pour le
peuple palestinien
je veux dire aux palestiniens pensez au
maire israélienne qui pleurent les
membres de leur famille tuée dans l'oeuf
dans les attentats elle éprouve la même
douleur que les mères palestiniennes à
qui on annonce la mort brutale d'un des
leurs
je veux le dire avec une profonde et
sincère amitié pour le peuple israélien
écoutez ce que criait la jeunesse des
printemps arabes
ils criaient vive la liberté ils ne
criaient pas à bas israël
vous ne pouvez pas rester immobiles
alors que ce vent de liberté et de
démocratie souffle dans votre région
je le dis avec une profonde et sincère
amitié pour ces deux peuples qui ont
tant souffert
le moment est venu de bâtir la paix pour
les enfants de palestine et pour les
enfants d'israël
mais il serait trop accablant que
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
ne profite pas de l'opportunité du
réveil des peuples arabes au service de
la démocratie pour régler un problème
qui fait le malheur de ces deux peuples
qui de toute façon sont condamnés à
vivre à côté les uns des autres
si nous prenons une solution de
compromis
nous redonnerons de la confiance et nous
redonnerons de l'espoir je veux le dire
avec gravité aux représentants de toutes
les nations nous avons une
responsabilité historique à assumer
c'est l'assemblée générale des nations
unies qui porte ce rendez vous avec
l'histoire
rassurons israël et donnons un espoir au
peuple palestinien
la solution est sur la table préféré
cette solution du compromis à celle du
blocage car le blocage satisfera
peut-être tout le monde ici mais il
créera des violences d amertume et des
oppositions qui mettront en péril le
réveil des peuples arabes et cela la
france vous dit que la tragédie doit
cesser pour une raison simple c'est
qu'elle n'a que trop duré je vous
remercie
nicolas sarkozy s'est donc exprimé
depuis l'assemblée générale des nations
unies à new york le chef de l'état a
précisé la position de la france sur la
demande de reconnaissance de l'état de
palestine
nicolas sarkozy propose donc le statut
d'état observateur aux nations unies
ce qui serait selon lui un signe
d'espoir pour les palestiniens
nicolas sarkozy propose un calendrier
d'un an pour parvenir à cet accord
mahmoud abbas déposera vendredi sa
demande officielle de reconnaissance de
l'état de palestine une démarche rejetée
il y à quelques minutes par barack obama
à la tribune de l'onu nicolas sarkozy va
poursuivre lui son déplacement à new
york
dans quelques instants il rencontrera
benyamin netanyahou le premier ministre
israélien avant un entretien ce soir
avec barack obama
et demain nicolas sarkozy prononcera un
discours à l'occasion du 125e
anniversaire de la statue de la liberté
un discours que vous pourrez bien sûr
suivre sur les chaînes parlementaires
ce sera à partir de 16h30
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
hu